okay let's let's play with someone who
will beat me clearly winston is too good
very very promising young grandmaster
uh
okay
so d4 i don't know
let's play a regular opening
once because he plays c5 and okay after
c5 i don't have so many cheapers like
after e5 no king's gambit
only neither
finally a guy beats me
as they say in hearthstone justice
demands retribution
okay maybe h4
uh
i don't remember what i'm supposed to do
here queen g2 or queen
or either way okay maybe queen g2
so this pawn is nothing
i'm between the two is the move like it
doesn't matter i'm already lost i
believe
okay sure i should take this
now what do i do
actually i don't think i lost any more
now i'm more optimistic
uh surprisingly
so what about the g5
and okay this is the kind of the time
for the player who wants to flag me
i feel i feel that i feel like
this is his actual problem he plays he
plays like not the best moves but he
answers like immediately
queen before of course trying to make me
in one
i'm not going to fall into this not
today winston
not today
could i win a queen uh not yet probably
but it was close like look the rook
before
shoot again almost winning the queen
almost is never enough
[Laughter]
yeah we've done that we've done that we
want to queen
the cheaper cheapo worked finally
sorry vincent
i'm very sorry didn't mean to do this to
you
well i can play okay i can't even i
can't even blonde roommate here
hard times hard times can't even wonder
i made
so if you cannot blend a roommate try to
give a match instead
we can sacrifice something something
else here like we can now sacrifice
what else
ah we are not interesting choice we're
going to just win yeah in a boring
fashion good old boring fishing i think
vincent's coach
mr incredible mr petroleka would be
we would be proud of him okay sorry but
thank you for the game
i actually watch you next time